[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben die liebe einer von dem
kanal meine rezepte und ihrem pferd
kanal meine torten und kuchen welt hat
eine unter kooperation für euch
gestartet außerdem machen mit es los
annika von genutzt voltaire emilio
romani und die liebe claudia von making
of bei mir gibt es heute eine super
leckere torte bequem tiefs ostring und
einer hübschen osterdekoration mein ruby
kuchen mache ich immer ohne butter und
öl denn wir verwenden viele möhren
stattdessen und die machen den teig so
klar saftig das sind 350 gramm 500 gramm
gemahlene nüsse ich habe jemanden bis 50
gramm mehl 200 gramm zucker optional
eine handvoll gehackte walnüsse aber das
bringt noch mal bitte den teig einen
teelöffel vanille extrakt und eine halbe
packung backpulver
zuallererst gebe ich die eier in meine
ruhe schritte gebe dann zucker und
vanille extrakten vorschlage dass krieg
drei bis vier minuten lang cremig
soweit die masse dann helfen kann das
mehl dazu und auch das backpulver und
noch einmal kurz unter gerührt werden
[Musik]
nach nämlich die schüssel aus der
maschine und gebe die gemahlenen mandeln
und auch die gehackten walnüssen im zu
und rühre sie einmal kurz unter zu guter
letzt werden noch die möhren
untergerührt und damit der teig auch
schon fertig und den finde ich jetzt in
meine 26 zentimeter springform und
backen sie bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für zirka 30 bis 35 minuten
in meinem fall war es schon nach 30
minuten fertig und den lasse ich jetzt
vollständig abkühlen für das green juice
forsting benötigen wir 400 milliliter
kalte sahne 350 gramm fisch käse 30
gramm puderzucker vier teelöffel seiner
fahrt für die sahne sowie vier teelöffel
seiner fahrt für den frischkäse und ein
esslöffel zitronensaft als erstes wie
die sahne mit dem hand liegt für eine
halbe minute lang aufgeschlagen
anschließend kommt dass seine tat dazu
und wird so lange weiter geschlagen wird
es komplett steife
die sahne kommt jetzt erst mal kurz in
den kühlschrank und so lange wird der
frischkäse zusammen mit dem zitronensaft
und dem verkehr einmal zusammen vermisst
jetzt kommt auch hier das donnerstag mit
dazu und sieht noch mal gut untergerührt
jetzt kann die sahne auch schon wieder
aus dem kühlschrank genommen werden und
wird mit einem text aber unberührt
und damit ist auf creams posting auch
schon fertig und für die deko benötigen
wir einen großen hasen zwei kleiner
sowie ein paar ostereier wir sind hier
auf maxi farben und zwei packungen oster
graf das sind essbare aufladung und
findet ihr zur osterzeit in jedem
supermarkt
das oster glas muss zuallererst in
kleines stückchen geschnitten werden
dafür eignet sich am besten eine küchen
schere für die größe einer 26 cm
springform werden allerdings auf jeden
fall zwei packungen benötigt ein
rückblick ohren habe ich mir auch meine
tortenplatte gelegt und gäbe da jetzt
das triemli softing drauf und
verstreiche das rundherum aber müsst ihr
auch überhaupt nicht ordentlich arbeiten
denn das sieht man am ende sowieso nicht
mehr
jetzt kommt der spaßige teil des kloster
graf einmal auf dem kuchen verteilt
werden und auf dem cremigen greenpeace
forsting kann das gras auch wunderbar
haften
jetzt verteidigt noch die osterhäschen
auf dem kuchen da schaue ich erst mal
wohl immer auf die platzieren möchte
mache mir dann etwas platz mit dem
löffel damit die finnen in die creme
stecken kann
zum schluss nur noch die hübschen
ostereier auf dem glas verteilen und
dann ist um so wunderschöne oster torte
auch schon fertig die oster torte hat
uns allen so gut geschmeckt berief die
kuchen ist nämlich durch die vielen
möhren richtig saftig geworden und auch
nichts zu sehen und das frosting ohne
das ganze perfekt ab auch wenn das oster
glas eigentlich nur für die optik kalt
fand ich das mit dem s papier einfach
mega lecker und vergisst bitte auch
nicht bei den anderen vorbei zu schauen
die haben so leckere kreationen für euch
vorbereitet lass dich inspirieren schaut
bei ihnen vorbei ich schreibe euch alle
kanäle unten in die infobox
und falls euch meine oster torte
gefallen hat freue ich mich natürlich
über einen daumen hoch und über euer abo
damit ihr auch nichts mehr verpasst bis
zum nächsten mal auf die key sketchen